baby walkers help babies walk baby
walkers do not help babies lock picking
up a crying baby will spoil them I think
I have a crying baby I'm putting honey
on a dummy aka a pacifier will help with
teething this is a dangerous mess
actually teething can cause beavers I
get paged about this myth all the time
hi and welcome I'm dr. Blair Hammond I'm
a general pediatrician at Mount Sinai
Hospital and I'm dr. ELISA Pressman I'm
a developmental psychologist and
co-founder of the Mount Sinai parenting
center the other co-founder the other
together today we're going to be
actually talking about debunking myths
with babies ready ELISA let's do it all
right
first babies who walk and talk early are
the brightest of their peer group even
though an early talker may tend to do
better in language skills later in life
it doesn't mean that children who are
not early talkers aren't going to equal
or rise above those talkers and with
Walker's which is a different thing
that's motor development motor
development is better at predicting
delays and associations with other
issues that may arise so if you notice
there's a delay in walking that's an
important thing to talk to your
pediatrician about but it is not
necessarily true or likely true that an
early Walker is going to get you into
Harvard never wake a sleeping baby and
this is a myth in particular in the
first few weeks of life so no more
babies really need to feed frequently
and if you happen to have a sleepy baby
you would actually wake them every 3 to
4 hours to feed at that time that's
right between 5 and 6 weeks of age day
and night sleep is organized so if
they're sleeping more than three three
and a half hours during the day at that
point
you really want to give them a little
nudge so that you can get them nice
consolidated sleep in the nighttime as
children get older you can let them
sleep longer periods of time lullabies
help babies sleep this one is actually
sort of a myth but not completely
because the act of singing a lullaby
that calming music can calm both you and
your baby but it isn't a magic pill that
is going to make sure that your baby
falls asleep finding ways to soothe your
infant especially using music and touch
is of course going to relax them and
induce a sleepier state naps aren't
necessary of any young children and
babies naps are necessary very I always
say the people who are like I'm gonna
keep my baby up all day so they sleep
all night in that first year of life
you're gonna have an angry baby yeah and
that is not gonna be a fun baby to take
care of and in fact in this young age
especially that first year of life we
really do focus on naps to help your
baby actually learn better control their
behavior and fall asleep better yeah as
an overly tired baby is actually going
to sleep worse you really need to keep
even one nap you don't want your infant
or toddler awake more than about five
hours at a time so up until three years
of age naps are really important for
daytime behavior emotional development
and nighttime organized consolidated
sleep babies should be sleeping through
the night by three months we all go for
that every mother wishes that if your
baby isn't sleeping through the night
because they need to have a feeding or
two feedings that's okay
up until four months you really want to
let your infant direct how that's gonna
go and then starting after four months
between four and six months you can
think about your influence on their
nighttime sleep and you might lose your
friends if you keep bragging about your
three months old who's sleeping through
the night and they
three-month-old who's not certain toys
will make babies smarter right myth the
myth is that it's the toy making the
baby smarter what helps your baby grow
smarter is the interaction between you
and your baby while playing with a toy
if you just stick a baby down with a
bunch of blocks your baby is not growing
smarter from those toys the best way to
grow your baby's brain and that first
year of life is through interaction with
a caregiver and you can then talk about
the toy describe the toy support your
infants discovery of the toy through
language and descriptions but the toys
itself are never going to make your baby
smarter another thing to keep in mind is
that when you are playing with your baby
you might find yourself using a singsong
voice with high-pitched sounds and like
a big exaggerated face and some people
might even think you're talking baby
talk the truth is that that is called
perrenties and it is one of the most
important uses of language when you use
that voice and you say like look at that
block you're playing with is that a
brown block are you putting that on top
of a blue block the important part of
that is that your language is so
engaging that parent D is actually is
associated with such boosts in language
development later in life now baby talk
where you're saying Google glad that the
data that is not useful for anyone
except if it gives you tremendous
delight and you just can't help yourself
all you like and you really just need to
just get in there with that baby it's
your language and your interaction and
your use of parent DS that's gonna
really get you that boost in
intellectual development that you are
hoping to get from the toy bouncing
babies will cause them to be bowlegged I
hear this all the time
in fact I have lots of parents say to me
right after our baby's born
oh no he's bowlegged an interesting
thing is it's because when a baby is in
the world most babies actually have
their legs crossed so they come out a
little boat looking and it
normal for the legs to actually have
that appearance and many babies have
that instinct to want to stand and bear
weight on their legs and that is
actually fantastic for their motor
development you're socially engaging
with them but you're also helping them
develop muscle strength and control so
this is absolutely a myth many
grandparents are into it they're also
like don't let your baby sit till
they're ready because it's gonna ruin
their back that is another myth I would
only add you don't need a contraption so
a jumper is not a good way great point
help a baby develop yep because they go
more on the toes and that's something
that's not recommended by most
developmental specialist excessive
crying means something is wrong if
you're feeling like your infant is
excessively crying the first thing that
you want to do is talk to your
pediatrician to make sure that there
isn't anything wrong medically you sort
of do a one over on your whole baby to
make sure all right my baby seems okay
my baby's fed my baby's peed whatever
what's going on here and then often it's
just they're so awake and frazzled they
can't calm their body down at this young
age the most fussy period is between
three to six weeks of life and there is
something called infant colic which
people have probably heard about and the
definition of colic is crying at least
three hours a day at least three days of
the week for at least three weeks a good
thing I tell parents is if the baby
calms down when you're shaking them
shaking them in a gentle rocking way
pushing them and you're like oh if I
hold the baby they stop crying but every
time I put them down they cry that's
reassuring
to me that there's not some real painful
issue going on and that the baby is
comforted by you and just needs that
help in general I say to people if the
baby cries more than an hour straight
and nothing is calming them down check
in with your pee
nutrition and you could be doing
everything right and it's not going to
stop the baby from crying in the short
term but again you will be helping their
long-term development picking up a
crying baby will spoil them it's not a
crying baby and don't let anybody tell
you otherwise people are often very
worried about spoiling young infants
please spoil your young infants yes fall
in love I see my job as a pediatrician
is to help you fall in love with your
baby I want you to touch that baby I
want you to snuggle the baby and the
feeling a baby has of being upset and
crying and stress and then when they
come with you that actually teaches
their brain to go from upset to come and
that is a life skill now as your child
gets older can you spoil a baby or child
who's crying and saying I need lollipops
for dinner yes obviously do not then
just pick them up and give them a
lollipop that is a totally different
thing in these first months of life
comforting your baby and calming their
body down actually helps them be calmer
humans long-term Oh putting honey on a
dummy aka a pacifier um will help with
teething this is a dangerousness
actually some myths are just like your
friends are talking about that don't
believe it this one is actually
dangerous babies should not have honey
in the first year of life and the risk
of honey comes from a bacteria called
botulism the spores from botulism your
body can process but young infants
cannot and it can actually cause
paralysis meaning a paralyzed limp and
thin which could be quite dangerous
life-threatening obviously no honey in
the first year of life for any baby
it's really something everyone should
know baby walkers help babies walk baby
walkers do not help babies walk in fact
there are some small studies that show
that baby
who use Walker's walk later than the
babies that do not use walkers do not
get a walker because you want your
baby's muscles to develop the way
they're supposed to without contraptions
the AAP that's the American Academy of
Pediatrics recommends against walkers
number one because they do delay walking
but number two because children can
actually fall and walkers fall down
stairs and walkers and have the ability
to reach things that are developmentally
inappropriate like hot stoves hot waters
I've had many patients be like oh my
gosh we put it on a registry and I feel
so bad I already got it
return it teething can cause fevers I
get paged about this myth all the time
people will say my baby has a 103 fever
it's just because they're teething
teething should not cause fevers it
might make your baby a little more fussy
it might make them eat a little less but
it should not cause fever it should not
cause coughing it should not cause runny
nose vomiting all those things make me
think your baby has some type of
infection something else going on so if
you have a fever and you're concerned
about the cause check in with your
pediatrician babies need water when it's
hot this is certainly a myth especially
in the beginning of life so the first
month of life some parents and
grandparents will say your baby needs
water it's hot out your babies should
not be given water we say breast milk or
formula only for newborn babies their
kidneys are actually immature and giving
water could mess up their electrolytes
and be quite dangerous in fact as your
child gets older around six months of
life we do encourage you to introduce
water for your child but in general many
people are under the impression like Oh
water is a better hydration fluid then
breast milk or formula but actually
breast milk and formula are grapes
hydrating babies you should avoid giving
peanuts fish and eggs to your child
until they're a toddler this was a big
math and in fact it used to be supported
by the medical community but there now
is really strong data showing that
actually earlier introduction increases
what we call tolerance meaning that you
won't have an allergic reaction but
there in fact is even an FDA
recommendation that infants between four
to six months of life have peanut
products introduced into their diet
because there is such compelling data
about the reduction in food allergy I
always say speak with your pediatrician
about exactly how to start it and if you
have specific family risk factors again
I may emphasize the one food you do not
introduce no honey till one year playing
classical music can make your babies
smarter playing classical music will be
one of the many things that you can do
certainly to surround them with the
kinds of stimulating auditory
experiences that will engage their brain
however playing classical music in and
of itself is not going to make your baby
smarter actually the back and forth
interactions that a baby has with a
caregiver where they hear real words
usually spoken in your native language
so that you can speak with most
expression and you're showing delay and
responding to the baby that is what
promotes the language development and
the social development of the brain the
best a newborns length will tell you how
tall they'll be lots of parents
obsessively think about the growth chart
I will confess I sometimes obsessively
think about my children's growth chart
the biggest predictor of your child's
final height is actually parents height
so we call something mid parental height
as the best predictor and another big
predictor is when the base the child
goes through puberty so usually the
longer you delay puberty the more years
of growth you have
so there are some children who are short
in 7th grade but they keep growing and
they're still growing in eleventh and
twelfth grade and then they catch up and
surpass their peers so it gives you an
idea it is certainly not the predictor
of your child's long term life you're
gonna hear many myths and many things
that are gonna make you question your
own parenting what we would emphasize is
try to think about your gut what makes
you feel good because a parent who feels
good and empowered is going to have
better interactions with their baby and
if you do have any questions rather than
thinking about the myths that are out
there seek advice from very reliable and
valid resources go to your pediatrician
with any questions or find the websites
that are actually valid and reliable and
never do Google searches arbitrarily or
look at chat rooms and again
pediatricians we go into this field
because we like to partner with parents
to making sure all children are as
healthy as possible so bring your
questions to the doctor